we do have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p
here's an interesting thing a caller
says his girlfriend's refusing to vote
take a listen to this hi David um I'm a
college student living in Minnesota
right I'm 21 years old but I'm 20 years
old and my girlfriend is about the same
age as me she's 21 she's also a college
student here and she is quite reluctant
to vote I was wondering and the reason
she says that she's reluctant to vote is
that she doesn't feel like she has the
time to inform herself on the candidate
as much as she said to vote she's not as
involved politically as I am I'm pretty
progressive basically in line with you
and Kyle kolinsky but she considers
herself more towards the centrist well
not super informed of the issues what
what do you suggest I say to try and get
her to vote more and I don't care how
she votes well I have preferences
obviously beador my the important thing
I see is getting her and other people to
vote what do you suggest for that thank
point one not voting is not a neutral
decision when you don't vote you are
making a very definitive decision number
one generally it helps the right maybe
she wants to do that maybe she doesn't
but not voting because she doesn't feel
informed on the issues is still making
the election potentially change in terms
of its result not voting would have won
the 2016 presidential election by
electoral votes easily in 2016 only in
two states was the plurality voting for
someone right so the non voters if that
was a contingent would have gotten way
more electoral votes than Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton if we consider it
that way I would explain to her she
doesn't have the time not to vote
because by taking the shortcut now and
saying I'm not going to get informed and
I'm not going to vote and I just punched
my mic because I'm so agitated by this
and I apologize for that she is going to
end
in the future needing to sink all sorts
of time into fixing problems that come
as a result of the fact that not enough
people vote so not voting is a decision
it's not a neutral decision it has a
huge impact and quite frankly I don't
I'm not saying we need mandatory voting
but if people really saw voting as their
duty rather than as this thing that if
they want to do it they do it but only
40 to 50 percent of people do it we
would be much better off we would be
much better off even if people the first
time they voted did vote the wrong way
once you vote you have more of a stake
and you pay more attention to what's
going on and then hopefully you revise
your future votes on the basis of the
consequences of your previous votes yeah
and you know maybe there are things on
the ballot that she's not so informed
with that she can skip as a you know a
question like if it's a ballot
initiative she's not very informed on
just just pass on that one but they got
a vote for the elective you gotta vote
for Congress you gotta vote for Senate
you gotta vote for governor this stuff's
important yes not voting is a very
impactful decision and the idea that if
you're uninformed and you opt out and
that's just a nice neat tidy solution
doesn't work great bonus show today
including a gun-toting lyft driver that
I had in Las Vegas over the weekend good
bonus show today don't miss it